Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hola y bienvenidos to The Rest is History, or should I say, Tom Holland, Merhaba, Salam Aleikum. Now, we are in the middle of our great World Cup odyssey, and we have reached the Kingdom of Spain. But Tom, you have chosen a topic from Spanish history before the Kingdom of Spain existed, haven't you? And one of the most colourful and dramatic topics in all European history. I have. It is, as your exemplary mastery of languages introduced at the beginning of this, suggested, it is the Caliphate of Córdova, which is the golden age of Muslim Spain. Cordova, the greatest city in Western Europe, its peak. So I want to look at how a caliphate came to be established in Spain,
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。各位好，欢迎来到《历史的 rest》，或者我该说，汤姆·霍兰，Merhaba，Salam Aleikum。现在，我们正处于伟大的世界杯漫游之旅的中途，我们已经到达了西班牙王国。但是汤姆，你选择了一个在西班牙王国成立之前的西班牙历史主题，对吧？而且是整个欧洲历史上最丰富多彩、最戏剧化的主题之一。是的。正如你刚才在开头展示的卓越语言掌控能力所暗示的那样，这是科尔多瓦哈里发国，也就是穆斯林西班牙的黄金时代。科尔多瓦，西欧最伟大的城市，在其鼎盛时期。所以我想探讨一下哈里发国是如何在西班牙建立的，
its golden age, and its decline. So that's the plan, Dominic. So this is the world of, if anybody's been there, so I've been there, I guess you've probably been there, Tom, to Cordova, to the wondrous edifice that is the Mezquita. So basically this extraordinary building that is the most magnificent mosque with a massive great cathedral. Well, it's not. Yeah. Yeah.
它的黄金时代以及它的衰落。这就是我们的计划，多米尼克。所以，如果有人去过那里的话，这就是那个世界——我去过那里，我想你大概也去过那里，汤姆——去过科尔多瓦，去过那座奇妙的建筑——大清真寺（Mezquita）。基本上，这座非凡的建筑是最宏伟的清真寺，里面有一座巨大的大教堂。嗯，其实不是。对。对。
So it got reconquered by the Christians in the long run and got converted into a cathedral. They just, I mean, it's the most, yes, it's the most appalling. And Dominic, do you know my solution to the whole Hagia Sophia, Cordova Mosque solution? It's basically they swap. Oh, yes, that is a good idea. So the Mosque of Cordova becomes a mosque. Yeah.
所以从长远来看，它被基督徒重新征服并改建成了大教堂。它们只是，我的意思是，这简直是，是的，这是最骇人听闻的。多米尼克，你知道我对整个圣索菲亚大教堂和科尔多瓦清真寺问题的解决方案是什么吗？基本上就是它们互换。哦，是的，那是个好主意。所以科尔多瓦清真寺变成清真寺。对。
And Hagia Sophia becomes a cathedral. That's an excellent idea. And everyone's happy. So that's my way. But this is not about bringing solutions to contemporary geopolitical problems. This is about history, Dominic. So in the public mind, Tom, this caliphate is this sort of lost golden age, this paradise of babbling fountains, people in hospitals, kindly philosophers, multiculturalism.
圣索菲亚大教堂变成大教堂。这是一个极好的主意。每个人都很高兴。这就是我的方法。但这并不是为了给当代的更地缘政治问题带来解决方案，这是关于历史，多米尼克。所以在公众心目中，汤姆，这个哈里发国是一种迷失的黄金时代，是一个潺潺流水、有医院、有仁慈的哲学家、有多元文化主义的天堂。
Munching on oranges, listening to the tinkling of fountains. Exactly. People drinking sherbet, all this sort of stuff. Am I on the right track? Well, kind of on the right track. I mean, it is a great, great centre of urban imperial civilisation of a kind that would have been familiar to the Romans and indeed to people in Constantinople and Baghdad at the time. And it's of a different order of sophistication to anything that you would have got, say, in France or Germany or England at the time. Does that mean it was a multicultural paradise? Well, we will explore and find out. But I think that to put it in its context, we should go back to the beginning of how it is that large chunks of Spain comes under Muslim rule, under Arab rule.
一边嚼着橙子，一边听着清泉的叮咚声。没错。人们喝着果子露，诸如此类的事情。我走对方向了吗？嗯，某种程度上算走对了方向。我的意思是，这是一个伟大、伟大的城市帝国文明中心，这种文明对于罗马人，以及当时的君士坦丁堡和巴格达的人民来说都是熟悉的。而且它的复杂程度与你当时在法国、德国或英国所能找到的任何东西都不在一个量级。这是否意味着它是一个多元文化的天堂？嗯，我们会去探讨并找出答案。但我认为，为了将它置于其背景中，我们应该回到西班牙大片领土归于穆斯林统治、阿拉伯统治之下的起点。
And in a way, this is a sequel to an episode that we've already done on the one episode we did on Saudi Arabia, on the Kaaba, where there was a dynasty called the amayads played quite a key role and the greatest of these figures was abdul malik the guy who builds the dome of the rock and who just conceivably perhaps plays the key role in fixing the sacrality of mecca for future generations um so the amayads are the first great imperial dynasty of the Caliphate. And they preside over this age of astonishing imperial expansion on a kind of unprecedented speed and scale. And they spread eastwards as far as the frontiers of China, but they also spread westwards. And they go along the southern shoreline of the Mediterranean and they come all
从某种程度上说，这是我们之前做过的一集关于沙特阿拉伯、关于克尔白（Kaaba）的节目的续集，在那一集里，有一个叫做倭马亚（Umayyad）的王朝发挥了相当关键的作用，其中最伟大的人物是阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik），也就是建造圆顶清真寺（Dome of the Rock）的人，他可能在为后代确定麦加的神圣性方面发挥了关键作用，嗯……所以倭马亚王朝是哈里发国的第一个伟大帝国王朝。他们主持了这个以空前速度和规模进行惊人帝国扩张的时代。他们向东一直扩张到中国边境，同时也向西扩张。他们沿着地中海南部海岸线前行，一直来到
the way to the Atlantic. And there, of course, the Pillars of Hercules, the straits separating Africa from Europe. And in 711, an Arab leader called Tariq bin Ziyad crosses over the straits of what will come to be called Gibraltar. And Gibraltar derives from the Arabic Jabal Tariq, the Mountain of Tariq. So that's what Gibraltar is. And he brings with him 10,000 men who are mostly Berbers, so from Morocco. And we talk about them, don't we, in our episode on Morocco. Don't know whether that's gone out yet or not,
大西洋。当然，在那里有海格力斯之柱（Pillars of Hercules），即把非洲和欧州隔开的海峡。公元711年，一位名叫塔里克·伊本·齐亚德（Tariq bin Ziyad）的阿拉伯领袖渡过了后来被称为直布罗陀的海峡。直布罗陀（Gibraltar）这个词源于阿拉伯语“Jabal Tariq”，即“塔里克山”。直布罗陀就是这个意思。他带来了10000名士兵，大多数是柏柏尔人，也就是来自摩洛哥的人。我们在关于摩洛哥的那一集里谈过他们，不是吗？不知道那一集播出没有，
because we're not sure what the running order is but uh ahead of them lies the land of spain to the romans hispania yeah you know a roman province for centuries and centuries deeply deeply romanized this is the homeland of trajan and of hadrian two of rome's greatest emperors with the fall the the collapse of roman power in the West, it gets taken over by a barbarian people called the Visigoths. And the Visigoths, as the Romans had been, are Christian. They've become Christian. In fact, they've become militantly Christian. And they are very, very into the idea of themselves as a kind of chosen people. So their capital in Toledo, in the centre of Spain, a new Jerusalem.
因为我们不确定播出顺序是怎样的，但是……在他们前方是西班牙的土地，对罗马人来说是伊斯帕尼亚（Hispania），是的，你知道的，这是一个历经几个世纪、深受罗马化影响的罗马行省。这里是图拉真（Trajan）和哈德良（Hadrian）的故乡，罗马最伟大的两位皇帝。随着罗马在西方权力的衰落和崩溃，它被一个叫做西哥特人（Visigoths）的蛮族接管了。西哥特人同当年的罗马人一样，是基督徒。他们已经皈依了基督教。事实上，他们已经变成了狂热的基督教徒。他们非常、非常热衷于将自己视为某种被选中的子民。因此，他们位于西班牙中部托莱多（Toledo）的首都，就是新耶路撒冷。
And they are the first Catholic people, Dominic, to practice anointing, the anointing of their kings. The anointing of kings. So when they have coronations, the Visigothic king is anointed. And this is a practice that we will witness in due course ourselves when the king gets anointed. Do you think the king in 2023, do you think he'll pay homage to his Visigoth forebears? I think it's unlikely, but in a way, the process, you know, standing there and being anointed, you're paying tribute to it, I guess, in a manner of speaking. I mean, it's a practice that derives from Israelite practice.
多米尼克，他们是第一批实行涂油礼——即为国王涂圣油——的公教（天主教）人民。国王的涂圣油仪式。因此，当他们举行加冕典礼时，西哥特国王会被涂上圣油。我们在适当的时候也会亲自见证这种国王被涂油的做法。你觉得在2023年，国王会向他的西哥特先辈致敬吗？我觉得不太可能，但从某种程度上说，站在那里接受涂油这个过程，你就是在向它致敬，我想，某种程度上可以说是这样。我的意思是，这是一种源自以色列人传统的做法。
And so, again, it's this idea that the Visigoths are a kind of, you know, a reborn chosen people. However, the idea that God is showing them special favor receives a massive knock when his 10 000 men turn up and annihilate the physiogothic king who musically is called roderick right oh no poor roderick so the defeat of king roderick he and his army get wiped out and this is very bad need for the Visigoths because their entire regime promptly collapsed like a kind of stack of cards. And the expanse of, it's difficult to know what to call them, the Moors, the Arabs, the Muslims. I mean, they're none of these things, really. They're a consortium of pillagers with kind of faint muslim overlay at this point they're not massively
所以，这也是那种认为西哥特人是某种，你知道的，重生的选民的想法。然而，当他的1万名士兵出现并歼灭了那位名字很具音乐感的西哥特国王——罗德里克（Roderick）时，上帝对他们格外青睐的想法受到了沉重打击，哦，不，可怜的罗德里克！因此，罗德里克国王的战败，他和他的军队被全歼，这对西哥特人来说是个极坏的消息，因为他们的整个政权随即像纸牌屋一样迅速崩溃。而这些人的扩张——很难知道该怎么称呼他们，摩尔人、阿拉伯人、穆斯林。我的意思是，他们实际上都不是这些。他们是一群掠夺者联盟，此时带有一点淡淡的穆斯林的色彩，他们当时并不是非常
motivated by the teachings of muhammad they're basically motivated by a desire for loot at this point and ethnically most of them you said were berbers most of them are berbers yeah so it's a huge kind of raiding party that just gets this you know just strikes massively massively lucky because the vithigothic regime is very, very rackety. It collapses. And these newcomers, these invaders are able to conquer pretty much the whole of what will become Spain and Portugal. And Christian powers are kind of left in the mountainous reaches of the North. So they maintain their independence, but they are impoverished, backward, cooped up in rugged terrain.
受到穆罕默德教义的强烈驱使，他们此时基本上是由对战利品的渴望所驱使的。从种族上讲，他们大多数人正如你所说的是柏柏尔人？大多数人都是柏柏尔人，是的。所以这是一支巨大的突袭部队，刚好获得了（你知道的）巨大的好运，因为西哥特政权非常、非常腐败。它崩溃了。这些新来者、这些侵略者得以征服了后来成为西班牙和葡萄牙的几乎全部领土。而基督教势力则被赶到了北部的山区。因此，他们保持了独立，但他们贫困、落后，被困在崎岖的地形中。
Right. So that's kind of, I'm just looking at the map, Galicia, Asturias, Navarre. The rest of Spain and what we call Spain and Portugal has now fallen beneath the... Comes under, yeah, exactly. So how are people to interpret this? Because dramatic events in this period are understood in supernatural terms. So theigoths you know they're saying what's happened we're meant to be the chosen people and so they blame it on the the penchant of too many visigoths as they see it for illicit sexual activities oh no what have they been up to same-sex activities uh basically what have they been doing men have been sleeping with men and women have been sleeping with women. And this is God's cross about this.
对。所以大致是这样——我正在看地图，加利西亚（Galicia）、阿斯图里亚斯（Asturias）、纳瓦拉（Navarre）。西班牙的其他地方以及我们现在所说的西班牙和葡萄牙，现在已经沦陷在……落入了……是的，完全如此。那么人们该如何解读这一切呢？因为这一时期的戏剧性事件都是从超自然的层面来理解的。所以西哥特人，你知道的，他们在说，发生了什么事？我们本来应该是选民啊。所以他们把这归咎于太多西哥特人（在他们看来）沉迷于非法的性活动。哦，不，他们都干了些什么？同性性活动，嗯，他们基本上都干了些什么？男人和男人睡觉，女人和女人睡觉。
And so he's punished them. So they take the view of sort of American televangelists from the 1970s. Yes, that's very much their take. For the Muslims, of course, this is brilliant. This is God's will. And the proof of this is that he's given them this great land and he's made them spectacularly wealthy. Because, you know, this is absolutely a classic imperial adventure. And the conquerors set out to exploit the lands that they have conquered
上帝对此非常生气。所以他惩罚了他们。因此，他们的看法就像是1970年代的美国电视福音传道者。是的，这非常符合他们的看法。当然，对于穆斯林来说，这太棒了。这是真主的意志。而这证明了真主把这片伟大的土地赐予了他们，并让他们变得极其富有。因为，你知道的，这绝对是一场经典的帝国冒险。征服者们开始以极大的热情
with great gusto. So they take lots of slaves. So a great chain of 30,000 slaves are sent off to Syria as a token of the conquest to the Umayyad court in Damascus. They plunder enormous amounts of loot. So they're not content with Spain. They start raiding deep into what will become France, into the kingdom of the Franks. And they impose a tax system on the conquered Christians and Jews. And this is prescribed in the Quran. It's a tax called
去开发他们征服的土地。所以他们抓了大量的奴隶。因此，作为征服的象征，一支由3万名奴隶组成的长队被送往叙利亚，献给大马士革的倭马亚宫廷。他们掠夺了大量的战利品。所以他们并不满足于西班牙。他们开始深入后来成为法国的法兰克王国境内进行掠夺。他们对被征服的基督徒和犹太人征收税收制度。这是《古兰经》中规定的。这是一种叫做
the jizya, which Christians and Jews are allowed to practice their faith. But in return, they have to acknowledge their inferiority in various ways, and they have to pay a tax. So they don't force people to convert. They don't really want people to convert because this is the source of their income. And can I just ask a quick question about this initial raid? Has it been ordered? Has it been done on a local basis? Or has it been ordered from Damascus by the Umayyad ruler? It's not entirely clear. I think that the Umayyads probably don't really have a sense of what's going on because it's a very, very long way.
吉兹亚（jizya，人头税）的税，基督徒和犹太人被允许信仰他们的宗教。但作为交换，他们必须以各种方式承认自己的劣势，并且必须交税。所以他们不强迫人们改宗。他们其实并不希望人们改宗，因为这是他们收入的来源。我能简单问一个关于最初这次袭击的问题吗？这是下令发起的吗？它是基于地方层面的行动？还是由大马士革的倭马亚统治者下令的？目前还不完全清楚。我认为倭马亚人可能并不太清楚发生了什么，因为这路途非常、非常遥远。
They just have a kind of vague sense that it's the will of God that their rule of the world expand the limits of the world. And so they're all in favor of that. But basically, it's up to the locals to take such advantage of this as they want. It's a kind of franchise, basically. I was just looking at the map. I mean, the Umayyad Caliphate, it's so interesting, isn't it, that it's so less well known than the Roman Empire or the Empire of Alexander the Great or any of these things. When you look at the map, it is unbelievably big.
他们只是有一种模糊的感觉，认为扩大世界疆域、扩大世界边界是真主的意志。所以他们对此完全赞成。但基本上，这取决于当地人如何根据自己的意愿来利用这一点。这基本上是一种特许经营权。我刚才在看地图。我的意思是，倭马亚哈里发国，太有趣了，不是吗？它比罗马帝国或亚历山大大帝的帝国或诸如此类的任何东西都要鲜为人知。当你看着地图时，它是如此难以置信的巨大。
I mean, the Spanish conquest is right on the western periphery. And as you said, it goes all the way basically to the borders of China and India. And it's so quick. It's such a vast process of conquest. And I think that in a way, it's the kind of the last of the great ancient imperial projects. It emerges in the old imperial heartlands of the Near East. And it conquers both Persian empires and huge numbers of provinces of the Roman Empire. And it absorbs them in. And these are lands that are used to being subject to distant emperors, distant rulers. And so I think that facilitates it enormously. And Spain comes to be known as Al-Andalus.
我的意思是，对西班牙的征服正处于其西部边缘。正如你所说，它一直延伸到中国和印度的边境。而且速度如此之快。这是一个如此庞大的征服过程。我认为，从某种程度上说，这是伟大的古代帝国项目的最后一个。它崛起于近东的旧帝国核心地带。它征服了波斯帝国和罗马帝国的广大行省。并将它们吞并进来。这些土地习惯于臣服于遥远的皇帝、遥远的统治者。所以我认为这大大促进了这一进程。西班牙后来被称为安达卢斯（Al-Andalus）。
It's unclear where this name comes from so some say that it echoes the vandals who would pass through and who um who passed through spain and come to to settle north africa yeah others say that maybe it's an allusion to atlantis oh i like that i've never heard that before i like that yeah so we're not sure but anyway it comes to be called al-andalus and spain is very rich land very rich in all kinds of, you know, its fields are rich. It's a very golden province. And so this is all hurrah. Yeah. Splendid news.
目前还不清楚这个名字的来历，所以有人说它呼应了汪达尔人（Vandals），他们曾穿过西班牙，并在北非定居下来，是的。另一些人则说，也许这是对亚特兰蒂斯（Atlantis）的暗示。哦，我喜欢这个，我以前从未听过这个，我喜欢这个，是的。所以我们不确定，但无论如何，它后来被称为安达卢斯，而西班牙是一片非常富饶的土地，在各方面都很富饶，你知道的，它的田野肥沃。这是一个非常繁荣的行省。所以这一切都值得欢呼。是的。好消息。
Everyone in Damascus is very pleased about it. However, the Umayyads do not stay in power. 750, they get toppled by a new dynasty, the Abbasids. And the tongue of the ruling caliph in Damascus is fed to a cat. So that's the end of him all the other are gathered together and crushed by the uh by their conquerors having a huge banquet on top of them so that's bad well and basically very very few umayyads survive this but one guy does and so in a way he's the kind of the aneas aneas escapes troy and goes off to found um rome the muslim equivalent of this the umayyadad equivalent of Aeneas is a guy called Abd al-Rahman bin Muawiyah.
大马士革的每个人都对此感到非常高兴。然而，倭马亚家族并没有一直掌权。公元750年，他们被一个新王朝——阿拔斯王朝（Abbasids）推翻了。大马士革统治哈里发的舌头被喂了一只猫。这就是他的结局。所有其他的家族成员都被聚集在一起，被他们的征服者压死，征服者在他们身上举行了一场盛大的宴会。所以这很糟糕。好吧，基本上只有非常、非常少数的倭马亚人在这场浩劫中幸存下来。但有一个人活了下来。所以从某种程度上说，他就像是埃涅阿斯（Aeneas）——埃涅阿斯逃离了特洛伊，去创立了罗马。穆斯林版本的埃涅阿斯，也就是倭马亚版本的
And he is the grandson of an Umayyad caliph. So he's quite distinguished and he's hunted across North Africa. And he spends five years on the run going ever further westwards, trying to escape Abbasid agents who are out to get him. And in 755, he arrives in Al-Andalus. And within a year, he has entered the capital of Al-Andalus, which is the great and ancient city of Cordoba. So a Roman foundation. It's where Seneca, the tutor of Nero had come from. And by the time that Abd al-Rahman arrives, it's been capital of Al-Andalus for about 40 years. It's replaced Seville.
埃涅阿斯是一个名叫阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼·伊本·穆阿维亚（Abd al-Rahman bin Muawiyah）的人。他是倭马亚哈里发的孙子。所以他相当显赫，他在北非遭到追捕。他在逃亡中度过了五年，越逃越往西，试图逃脱四处搜捕他的阿拔斯王朝特工。公元755年，他抵达了安达卢斯。不到一年，他就进入了安达卢斯的首府——伟大而古老的科尔多瓦城。这是一个罗马人的基石。尼禄的导师塞内卡（Seneca）就出身于此。当阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼抵达时，它作为安达卢斯首府已经有大约40年了。它取代了塞维利亚。
So he arrives and has the word not gone out? Detain this man, hand him over, you know? Al-Andalus is a long way from the Middle East. Right. It's a long way. And so, you know, I guess it's kind of a bit like the American colonies relative to, say, Britain during the period of the Civil War or something like that. People who wouldn't survive, say, in Britain can survive in the colonies. And so likewise, Abdulrahman is able to take possession of Cordova. And he has himself proclaimed emir, which is basically commander or prince, in the mosque of Cordova. So he's not proclaiming himself caliph, but he is calling himself emir right and he very
所以他到达了，难道消息没有传出去吗？扣留这个人，把他交出来，你知道的吗？安达卢斯距离中东很远。对。路途遥远。所以，你知道的，我想这有点像美国殖民地相对于内战时期的英国，诸如此类的情况。在英国无法存活的人可以在殖民地存活。因此，同样地，阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼也能够在科尔多瓦占有一席之地。他在科尔多瓦的清真寺自立为埃米尔（emir），也就是指挥官或亲王。所以他没有自称哈里发，但他称自己为埃米尔，对，而且他
pointedly does not allow prayers to be offered for the abbasid caliph in distant baghdad i mean given that this bloke had a banquet on the bodies of his family i think that's perfectly reasonable exactly but obviously he's surrounded by all kinds of people who have no particular investment in the survival of the Umayyads. But he proves himself very, very capable at establishing his power. So he rules for about, I think, for 33 years. He establishes a very impressive degree of military and economic self-sufficiency. He crushes all his potential rivals within Spain. And he also suppresses every Abbasid attempt to kick him out of Al-Andalus. And he actually beheads the leader of one of these expeditions, pickles the head and sends it back to the Abbasids. And there's quite a lot of beheading
非常刻意地不允许为远在巴格达的阿拔斯哈里发祈祷。考虑到这家伙曾在他的家族尸体上举办过宴会，我认为这完全合情合理。完全正确。但很明显，他周围环绕着各种对倭马亚王朝的存亡没有任何特殊投入的人。但他证明了自己建立权力的能力非常、非常强。所以他统治了大约，我想是33年。他建立了一种令人印象深刻的军事和经济自给自足程度。他在西班牙国内粉碎了所有潜在的竞争对手。他还镇压了阿拔斯王朝每一次企图将他赶出安达卢斯的尝试。他实际上将其中一次远征的领袖斩首，把头颅腌制起来，然后送回给阿拔斯王朝。这一时期有相当多的斩首事件。
in this period going on. I actually quite enjoy that in a podcast. Not in real life, but in a podcast, I can live with it. if you like beheading you'll love this so dominic you mentioned the the great mosque of cordova this beautiful astonishing and comparable building um abdulrahman is the guy who begins it so he begins it in 785 traditionally it is said to have been built on the site of a christian cathedral that the cathedral in uh sacred to john the Baptist, that this cathedral, the Muslims had come and they had taken over half of it. And then with Abdulrahman, they take over the whole lot, level it and build the mosque on the site. It's not 100% certain that that happened. The debate around this is quite political.
我其实挺喜欢播客里有这种情节的。不是在现实生活中，而是在播客里，我完全能接受。如果你喜欢斩首，你会爱死这一集的。所以，多米尼克，你提到了科尔多瓦大清真寺，这座美丽、惊人且无与伦比的建筑。阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼就是开始建造它的人。他在公元785年开始动工。传统上说，它是建立在一座基督教大教堂的遗址上的，那座奉献给施洗者约翰的大教堂，穆斯林来到这里并占领了它的一半。后来在阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼时期，他们占领了全部，将其夷为平地，并在原址上建造了清真寺。这并不是100%确定发生的。围绕这一点的争论具有相当的政治色彩。
As you can imagine, there are kind of very strong feelings on Christian side, on Muslim side. It's certainly possible. And at the very least, it's built on a kind of, as you know, a center of Christian power. And so therefore, building the mosque is making a statement about the supersession of Christianity, that Islam has replaced it. And this is visible in the very fabric of the mosque, because what the architects do is they take columns from pagan temples, from Christian churches. They have a very, very distinctive style where the arches alternate brick with stone, white with red. And these arches are constructed according to Roman method,
你可以想象，基督教阵营和穆斯林阵营都有非常强烈的情感。这当然是可能的。而且至少，它建立在一个，你知道的，基督教权力的中心之上。因此，建造清真寺就是在宣示基督教的被取代，宣示伊斯兰教已经取而代之。这在清真寺的建筑结构中清晰可见，因为建筑师们从异教神庙和基督教堂中取来圆柱。他们有一种非常、非常独特的风格，拱门由砖块和石头交替砌成，白色与红色相间。这些拱门是根据罗马的方法建造的，
but there's a very kind of distinctive horseshoe style of the arches. And this is very visigothic. In due course, the Um emmaid rulers will construct a private prayer room and they will employ craftsmen from constantinople to gild it with exquisite mosaics so essentially the mosque bears witness to the absorption of defeated empires defeated cultures defeated faiths into the universal empire of Islam. And it is a magnificent, I mean, for anybody who hasn't, you know, whether you're listening to this podcast on the tube or going for a walk or whatever, do, if you haven't been, do Google the Mesquita of Cordoba, because it is a stunning building when you go and you see, people often say,
但拱门有一种非常独特的马蹄形风格。这非常具有西哥特风格。随后，倭马亚统治者将建造一个私人祈祷室，他们将雇用来自君士坦丁堡的工匠用精致的马赛克来镀金。所以，本质上，清真寺见证了被征服的帝国、被征服的文化、被征服的信仰被吸收到伊斯兰教的普世帝国中。而且它是一座宏伟的——我的意思是，对于任何还没有去过的人来说，无论你是在地铁上听这个播客，还是在散步等等，如果没有去过的话，一定要去谷歌一下科尔多瓦的梅斯基塔（Mesquita），因为当你去参观时，它是一座令人惊叹的建筑，人们经常说，
don't they, Tom, that the columns, which as you say, are from Roman temples or whatever, that they look like palm trees in an oasis or something, that there is this effect of walking into this forest of columns with the beautiful arches. It really is stunning. And even when the Christians in due course captured it and turned it into a cathedral, the complaint was, you know, you've ruined something that has no parallel anywhere in the world and that was a criticism of contemporaries you know in the 16th century it's charles v who does it anyway so this group this great mosque is built to serve as the center of an increasingly muslim population because um over the decades and then the centuries islam becomes ever more fashionable
汤姆，那些柱子正如你所说，来自罗马神庙或诸如此类的地方，它们看起来像绿洲里的棕榈树之类的，有一种走进这片柱林并配有美丽拱门的效果。这真的很令人惊叹。甚至当基督徒后来占领它并将其改建为大教堂时，当时的抱怨是，你知道的，你毁了一座在世界上无可匹敌的建筑。这是16世纪时人们的批评，无论如何，最终是查理五世（Charles V）这么做的。所以，这座宏伟的清真寺是为了服务于日益增多的穆斯林人口而建造的，因为几十年来、几个世纪以来，伊斯兰教变得越来越流行，
and cordova itself becomes ever more clearly a Muslim city. So the Roman street plan starts to vanish. Muslim traders, by and large, don't use carts. So there's no need for the kind of the broad streets that had existed in the Roman period. The wine market is closed. Spain had been a great center for the wine trade in the Roman empire, but no place for that in Islam. And by about 850, Christians in Cordova are feeling increasingly under siege. Basically, Islam is where it's at. It's fashionable.
科尔多瓦本身也越来越明显地成为一座穆斯林城市。因此，罗马时代的街道布局开始消失。穆斯林商人基本上不使用大车。因此，不需要罗马时期那种宽阔的街道。葡萄酒市场被关闭了。西班牙曾是罗马帝国葡萄酒贸易的中心，但在伊斯兰教中没有这个容身之地。到公元850年左右，科尔多瓦的基督徒感到越来越受到围困。基本上，伊斯兰教才是王道。它很时髦。
It's cool. Everyone's speaking Arabic. Muslim styles are everywhere. Christianity is coming to seem increasingly low status. You know, if you want a job in the bureaucracy, you basically got to be a Muslim. The fewer Christians there are, the more taxes are loaded on them. So it's financially demanding as well. So more and more people start to convert to Islam. And you get this extraordinary phenomenon in Cordova, where you get Christians who deliberately go out into the streets and attempt to court martyrdom by insulting the prophet. And the Muslim authorities don't you know, the Muslim authorities don't want, really want to act on this.
它很酷。每个人都在说阿拉伯语。穆斯林的风格无处不在。基督教的地位似乎越来越低。如果你想在官僚机构中找到一份工作，你基本上必须是个穆斯林。基督徒越少，强加给他们的税收就越多。所以这也是一种经济上的苛求。因此，越来越多的人开始皈依伊斯兰教。你会在科尔多瓦看到这种非凡的现象，那里的基督徒故意走上街头，通过侮辱先知来试图招致殉道。而穆斯林当局并不——你知道的，穆斯林当局并不真正想对此采取行动。
They don't want to kind of precipitate sectarian riots or anything like that. But you get Christians in Cordova who are deliberately trying to court martyrdom. And, you know, they duly do get martyred. And the whole thing gradually fizzles out. Because increasingly, Cordova is becoming ever more Muslim. So by about, you know, by 850, it's been estimated it's about 70 percent is muslim and the same is true out in uh in other urban settlements and increasingly the place where you find christians is out in the country so they're seen as that makes sense you know they're kind of associated with peasants but this generates a
他们不想引发宗派骚乱或诸如此类的事情。但科尔多瓦的基督徒却在故意寻求殉道。而且，你知道的，他们确实如愿以偿地殉道了。整个事情渐渐平息下去了。因为越来越明显的是，科尔多瓦正变得更加穆斯林化。所以到公元850年左右，据估计大约70%的人口是穆斯林。其他城市定居点也是如此。基督徒越来越只能在乡下找到。所以他们被视为——这说得通，你知道的，他们和农民联系在一起。但这产生了一个
problem because as you pointed out earlier, in a way, the Muslim authorities don't want mask versions because it diminishes the tax base, because you're dependent on Christians to pay the jizya. And so over the course of the ninth century, the state, the Emmaus state starts to fragment. And you have a process rather similar to what is starting to happen in France at the same time, where central power is diminishing and you are starting to get people putting up what you might call castles, fortifications, you know, on every crest of a hill. So sort of local warlords basically establishing their own bases. Yeah. And so you get kind of increasingly a state of anarchy. And by the beginning of the
问题，正如你刚才所指出的，在某种程度上，穆斯林当局并不希望出现大规模改宗，因为这会削减税收基础，因为你要靠基督徒来缴纳吉兹亚（人头税）。因此，在9世纪的过程中，国家、倭马亚国家开始走向分裂。你经历了一个与当时法国开始发生的情况相当相似的过程，即中央权力正在减弱，你开始看到人们在每一座山脊上建立你可以称之为城堡、防御工事的东西。基本上就是地方军阀建立他们自己的基地。是的。所以你越来越陷入无政府状态。到了
10th century, the authority of the Emmaids has essentially become confined to Cordoba. And the entire system could have collapsed. But, Dominic, there is an incredible comeback. And this is entirely down to a man called Abd al-Rahman III, who comes to power in 912 when he is aged 23. I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we will trace the course of his career, which witnesses the absolute golden age
10世纪初，倭马亚家族的权威基本上被限制在了科尔多瓦。整个系统本可能崩溃。但是，多米尼克，出现了一场令人难以置信的卷土重来。这完全归功于一个名叫阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼三世（Abd al-Rahman III）的人，他在912年上台，当时他23岁。我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将回顾他的生平轨迹，那见证了伊斯兰西班牙的绝对黄金时代。
of Islamic Spain. Excellent. And you talked about, you know, Sherbert and fountains and all that kind of stuff. His rule is pure Arabian nights. Excellent. So come back after the break
太棒了。你刚才谈到了果子露、喷泉和所有这些东西，他的统治简直就是纯粹的《一千零一夜》。太棒了。所以休息过后回来，
and you'll get Sherbert and fountains and you'll get the golden age of Islamic Spain. What's not to like? See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
你就能看到果子露和喷泉，你将迎来伊斯兰西班牙的黄金时代。有什么理由不爱呢？到时见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的秀场八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We promised you Sherbert and Fountains. Tom Holland, will you deliver? I certainly will. And it's all thanks to Abdelrahman III. This young man who comes to power, he is, I mean, he's not obviously charismatic. He's a little bit dumpy, I think.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们向你承诺过果子露和喷泉。汤姆·霍兰，你能兑现吗？我当然会。这一切都要归功于阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼三世。这个掌权的小伙子，我的意思是，他显然不是那种具有个人魅力的人。我觉得他稍微有点矮胖。
Dumpy? Yeah, a little bit dumpy. He's a little bit kind of portly. He's not the fittest. Right. Who would he be played by? Well, we've just had the suggestion from our producer, a young Jonah Hill. Yeah. I suggested a young Eddie Large hill yeah i i suggested young eddie large tom but that reference will be lost on some of our listeners i think anyway he's he is he is young he is a little bit dumpy and he is naturally depressive so he's prone to melancholy okay he is also um although he's an emmaid and from syria he he has fair hair and he has blue eyes. Oh, that's a twist. Because his mother was Frankish and the Umayyads have been marrying Christian slaves. Do the Umayyads have multiple wives, Tom?
矮胖？是的，稍微有点矮胖。他有点胖乎乎的。他不是身材最健美的。对。他会由谁来扮演呢？嗯，我们的制作人刚刚提出了一个建议，年轻时的乔纳·希尔（Jonah Hill）。对。我建议年轻时的埃迪·拉奇（Eddie Large），希尔，是的。我建议年轻时的埃迪·拉奇，汤姆，但这个梗会被我们的一些听众忽略，我想。无论如何，他是年轻的，他有点矮胖，而且他天生忧郁，所以他倾向于多愁善感，好吧。他也是，
They do, yes. They have concubines and all that carry on? All that malarkey. All that malarkey. And so Abdulrahman is rather self-conscious about this. And so he dyes his hair and he darkens his skin. He darkens his skin he darkens his skin yeah because he wants to he wants to look a kind of authentic amayad from the golden
虽然他是倭马亚人，来自叙利亚，但他长着金发和蓝眼睛。哦，这倒是个反转。因为他的母亲是法兰克人，而且倭马亚人一直在与基督教女奴结婚。倭马亚人有多个妻子吗，汤姆？
age of the dynasty so actually he should be played by justin trudeau yes okay so jonah hill crossed with justin trudeau that's it so he's so as i say he's not he's not naturally charismatic he's not a great general he's not a great general. He's not a religious leader, but he is, Dominic, he is very, very methodical. And he is a man with a plan. And the moment he becomes, he succeeds the rule of Cordova, he starts putting his plan into action. And basically his plan is to step by step overthrow everybody who is defying him and to destroy the power of all and every local lord out there. And he does this by targeting great cities like Seville, by targeting the smallest little fortified stronghold on a rocky outcrop. So he's like a man playing a board game or something.
他们确实有，是的。他们有妃嫔和所有这些乱七八糟的事情？所有的那些胡闹。所有那些乱七八糟的事情。所以阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼对此相当在意。因此他把头发染黑，并把皮肤弄深。他把皮肤弄深，他把皮肤弄深，是的，因为他想，他想让自己看起来像是一个黄金时代的根正苗红的倭马亚人。所以实际上他应该由贾斯廷·特鲁多（Justin Trudeau）来扮演。是的，好吧——所以是乔纳·希尔和贾斯廷·特鲁多的结合体，就是这样。所以他，正如我所说，他并不是天生具有个人魅力，他不是一个伟大的将领，他不是一个伟大的将领。他不是宗教领袖，但是，多米尼克，他非常、非常有条理。他是一个有计划的人。从他上台、继承科尔多瓦统治的那一刻起，他就开始付诸实施他的计划。基本上他的计划就是一步一步地推翻所有反抗他的人，摧毁所有地方领主的权力。他通过攻击塞维利亚等大城市，攻击岩石峭壁上最小的防御据点来实现这一点。所以他就像一个玩棋盘游戏的人之类的。
Yes. Hoovering up yeah exactly uh and he's very very good so he's he's prepared all kinds of siege engines uh he's commissioned these and he's very expert at using them um he practices economic warfare so he uh a particular thing is cutting down fruit trees very good at that okay and uh whenever he captures a fortress he makes it his own by putting in his own garrisons, his own deputies, his own rulers. And so the result of this is that step by step, without any spectacular victories, but inexorably, he comes to reconstitute the empire that his
是的，把它们横扫一空，是的，绝对是这样，而且他非常擅长这一点。他准备了各种攻城器械，他委托制作了这些器械，并且非常擅长使用它们。他实行经济战，所以他的一个特点是砍伐果树。非常擅长那个，好吧。每当他攻占一座要塞，他就通过安放自己的驻军、自己的副手、自己的统治者来把它变成自己的地盘。因此，其结果是，一步一步地，没有经历什么轰动性的胜利，但他毫不留情地重建了他祖先曾经宣称拥有的帝国。
ancestors had claimed. And this becomes a virtuous circle because as he reconstitutes this empire, so it starts to form a kind of single market. And this single market in turn can then be reintegrated with the much broader single market that is the caliphate beyond the limits of Al-Andalus. So does he have decent relations now with the Abbasid caliphate or do they still regard him? They still regard him as a usurper, but merchants don't really care about that because they're all Muslim. They all speak the same language. They all have the same culture.
这成了一个良性循环，因为随着他重建这个帝国，它开始形成一个单一市场。而这个单一市场反过来又可以与安达卢斯边界之外、那个更广阔的哈里发国单一市场重新融合。那么他现在与阿拔斯哈里发国的关系还算正经吗？还是他们依然视他为……他们依然视他为一个篡位者，但商人并不太在乎这一点，因为他们都是穆斯林。他们都说同样的语言。他们都有相同的文化。
And so if you're in Al-Andalus, you know, you have lots of things that you can sell. You have oil, all kinds of stuff like that. But you can import, you know, sandalwood from India or spices. Yeah. Camphor from Borneo. I mean, you know, the reach of the caliphate is enormous. It's from the Atlantic to China to Malaysia. You know, it's an enormous, enormous expanse. And so Al-Andalus, now that it's entire again, benefits from this. The other thing that Abdulrahman does is he
所以如果你在安达卢斯，你知道的，你有很多东西可以卖。你有油，还有各种诸如此类的东西。但你可以进口，你知道的，印度的檀香或香料。是的。婆罗洲的樟脑。我的意思是，你知道的，哈里发国的势力范围是巨大的。它从大西洋一直延伸到中国和马来西亚。你知道的，这是一个极其广阔的疆域。因此，安达卢斯现在既然重新成为一个整体，便从中受益。阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼做的另一件事是
launches jihad. And jihad, the idea that you exert yourself on behalf of God and is closely associated by kind of Muslim warlords with the practice of warfare against infidels, against Christians. And so he goes off to fight against the Christians of the North who've been gradually recovering. So these mountain kingdoms, basically. Yes, absolutely. And again, he kind of advertises this by a lot of beheadings. So I promised you beheadings. So a lot of heads of Christians are harvested and they're brought back and they're slung from the gates of the Great Mosque in Cordova. And these are kind of like billboards advertising his prowess. that basically by 929, so almost 20 years after he's come to power,
发起圣战（jihad）。圣战，即你为真主付出努力的想法，被穆斯林军阀与针对异教徒、针对基督徒的战争实践紧密联系在一起。所以他去与那些一直在逐渐恢复元气的北方基督徒作战。基本上就是这些山区王国。是的，完全如此。同样，他也通过大量的斩首来宣传这一点。所以我答应过你斩首。因此，许多基督徒的头颅被割下来带了回来，并被挂在科尔多瓦大清真寺的大门上。这些就像是宣传他英勇战绩的广告牌，
he is richer and more militarily potent than any Umayyad before him in Al-Andalus. And so in 929, he decides to take the ultimate step and promote himself to the level of caliph, which is a caliph is supposed to be the sole ruler of the house of Islam. Obviously, there is already a caliph in Baghdad, but Abd al-Rahman III isn't going to let a little technicality like that get in the way. And so he has himself proclaimed caliph in the great mosque in Cordova. And he has the wealth and he has the prestige and he has the military power to carry it off. So Tom, quick question on the assumption of the caliphate. Is there any, as it were, theological disagreement between him and the Abbasid caliphs?
基本上到公元929年，也就是他掌权近20年后，他在安达卢斯比以往任何一个倭马亚人都更富有，军事实力也更强。因此，在公元929年，他决定迈出终极一步，将自己晋升为哈里发。哈里发本应是伊斯兰世界的唯一统治者。显然，巴格达已经有一个哈里发了，但阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼三世不会让这样一个小小的技术细节挡道。因此，他在科尔多瓦的大清真寺自立为哈里发。他拥有财富、声望和实现这一目标的军事力量。所以汤姆，关于僭称哈里发的问题，我有一个小问题。他和阿拔斯哈里发之间是否存在某种，可以说是神学上的分歧？
Or is this purely a power play? No, there is no separation between politics and what we would mechanistically call religion. Everything is saturated with the ideals, the principles, the values of Islam. And so to lay claim to the rule of a caliphate is inevitably to make a theological statement. But there's nothing like a kind of sunny Shia split. No, it's not like that. It's not like that. But Abd al-Rahman is laying claim to the rule, not just of al-Andalus, you know, as commander of the faith rule, but of the whole Muslim world. I mean, that's obviously a joke. He doesn't have a hope of claiming that.
还是这纯粹是一场权力的博弈？不，政治与我们机械地称之为宗教的东西之间没有分离。一切都充斥着伊斯兰教的理想、原则和价值观。因此，宣称对哈里发国的统治，不可避免地是在发表一种神学声明。但这并不是什么类似逊尼派和什叶派分裂的东西？不，不是那样的。不是那样的。但阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼不仅在宣称对安达卢斯的统治——你知道的，作为信仰指挥官的统治——而是对整个穆斯林世界的统治。我的意思是，这显然是个笑话。他根本没有希望宣称这一点。
Basically, he has the heft to carry it off. That's the point. People don't laugh at him for doing it. It's not an obvious fraud. And the reason for that is that by this point, Cordova is, you know, is spectacularly large and wealthy. So it's, you know, population of 100,000. Crikey. So that would make it probably the biggest city in Western Europe, I guess? By miles. So the hyperbole that surrounds it is kind of ecstatic. It's a city of 900 baths, of 1,000 mosques, of tens of thousands of shops.
基本上，他有足够的份量来实现它。这就是重点。人们不会因为他这么做而嘲笑他。这并不是一个显而易见的骗局。原因在于，到这个时候，科尔多瓦（你知道的）已经变得极其宏大和富有。所以，你知道的，它的人口有10万。天哪。这大概会使它成为西欧最大的城市吧？远远超过其他城市。因此，围绕它的夸张赞美近乎狂热。这是一座拥有900座浴场、1000座清真寺、数万家商店的城市。
The libraries are on a prodigious scale. The Califal Library alone has 400,000 volumes. You have running water from aqueducts, you have paved streets. And for Muslims, Cordova ranks as a great capital. And for outsiders, you know, Christians from the Frankish North, it's spectacular. I mean, it's off the scale. They're stupefied by it. And we know that because we have the record of a visit to it by an abbot from the Rhineland called John, who goes there in 950. And John doesn't actually go to Cordova itself.
图书馆的规模极其庞大。仅哈里发图书馆就藏有40万册图书。你们有来自输水渠的自来水，有铺砌的街道。对于穆斯林来说，科尔多瓦堪称一座伟大的首都。而对于外来者来说，你知道的，来自法兰克北部的基督徒，它是壮观的。我的意思是，这超出了他们的想象。他们对此目瞪口呆。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们有莱茵兰的一位名叫约翰的修道院院长在950年访问那里的记录。约翰实际上并没有去科尔多瓦本身。
He goes to a place called Medinata Alzara, which is the kind of a Versailles that Abdulrahman has built outside Cordova. And John is overwhelmed by the spectacle. So he reports that the palace stretches for miles, that everywhere he looks, there are soldiers standing to attention, riding on horseback, maneuvering, doing drill. And John says that these soldiers filled our party with consternation, such was their arrogance and swagger. And even the gatehouses, John reports, are adorned with carpets and precious fabrics. There's a zoo that is moated. There are water features everywhere.
他去了一个叫麦地那·阿兹哈拉（Medinat Alzara）的地方，那是阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼在科尔多瓦城外建造的类似于凡尔赛宫的地方。约翰被眼前的景象震撼了。据他报道，这座宫殿绵延数英里，无论他看向哪里，到处都是立正站好的士兵、骑着马的士兵、在进行演练和操练的士兵。约翰说，这些士兵让我们的随行人员感到惊慌失措，他们的傲慢和神气活现就是如此。约翰还报道说，甚至连门楼都装饰着用地毯和珍贵的织物。有一个带护城河的动物园。到处都是水景。
And there's so many fish in it that it requires 12,000 loaves to feed them. And most spectacular of all, there is a great reception hall. And it has a pool of mercury in the middle. And you stir the mercury, and it sends shivers of reflected sunlight dancing across the decorated marble walls. And above this, the roof is made of gold and silver and hanging from it, there is a colossal pearl. And so, you know, this is the kind of vision of how a Caliph should live, the kind of haunts, the fantasies of Orientalists everywhere. And this is the beginning of that tradition. This is, you know, a Westerner going and being blown away by the spectacle of the wealth and
里面有那么多的鱼，以至于需要1,2000个面包来喂养它们。最壮观的是，有一个宏伟的接待大厅。它的中间有一个水银池。只要搅动水银，它就会让反射的阳光在装饰着大理石的墙壁上跳跃闪烁。在这之上，屋顶由黄金和白银制成，上面悬挂着一颗巨大的珍珠。所以，你知道的，这就是哈里发应该如何生活的愿景，这是世界各地东方主义者的梦想和幻想。这也是那个传统的开始。这就是，你知道的，一个西方人去参观并被哈里发宫廷的财富和
the power of the Caliphal Court. This is exactly what I was expecting from a podcast about the Caliphate of Cordoba, which is amazing beauty, splendor. The other thing I wanted to ask about, so does this all rest on a foundation of relative, now I know you have strong views about this, but relative tolerance, i.e. it sounds like an architectural paradise, but is it also a kind of cultural and religious paradise, I suppose? I know religious is an anachronistic word. So the idea of paradise is obviously very important in Islam. It's a faith that has grown up in areas of the world that are naturally quite parched and dry. And so the ability to sustain a paradise, a garden, is again, a marker
权力的景象所震撼。这正是我对一档关于科尔多瓦哈里发国的播客所期望的，那是惊人的美、壮丽。我还想问的另一件事是，这一切是否都建立在相对的——我知道你对此有强烈的看法——但相对宽容的基础上，也就是说，听起来它像是一个建筑上的天堂，但它同时也是一种文化和宗教上的天堂吗？我知道宗教是一个时代的错置词。所以天堂的概念在伊斯兰教中显然非常重要。这是一种在自然相当贫瘠干燥的世界地区发展起来的信仰。因此，维持天堂、花园的能力，再次成为了一个标志。
of greatness. And so that's why the idea of gardens, of fountains, of flowing water, of animals, of fish, is so important to the sense that the Muslims themselves in Al-Andalus have of the greatness of this palace, and therefore by extinction of how we today have it, because we, you know, these understandings of what true greatness is mediated back to us. I mean, it's not tolerant in the sense that we would understand it. It's not a secular society. It's proudly and militantly Muslim. And by this point, Christians and Jews not a secular society. It's proudly and militantly Muslim. And by this point, Christians and Jews are a tiny minority. They remain subordinate. Of course, their position within the caliphate is upheld by Islamic law. They submit, and in exchange for
极了不起的成就。因此，为什么花园、喷泉、流水、动物和鱼类的概念，对于安达卢西亚的穆斯林自身对这座宫殿的伟大的感知如此重要，从而推而广之，也决定了我们今天如何看待它，因为我们，你知道的，这种对什么是真正伟大的理解是通过各种渠道重新传给我们的。我的意思是，它并不是我们所理解的那种宽容。它不是一个世俗社会。它自豪且好战地信奉伊斯兰教。到了这个时候，基督徒和犹太人并非一个世俗社会。它自豪且好战地信奉伊斯兰教。到了这个时候，基督徒和犹太人是极少数。他们依然处于从属地位。当然，他们在哈里发国内的地位受到伊斯兰法律的维护。他们顺从，作为交换，为了
their submission, they're granted tolerance. Because they're people of the book. And this provides scope for what we might call kind of multicultural dialogue. So Muslim scholars and Christian scholars and Jewish scholars do meet. I think the multicultural angle can be massively overdone. And you see why people want to believe that there was a multicultural paradise back in the past that we can identify with. To be honest, the most multicultural activity in this period in the European context is the slave trade. So the reason why we call slaves slaves and not say the Latin word is servi is because large numbers of Slavs are being kidnapped and enslaved by the Saxons and the Franks on the Eastern frontier. This is how they are making their money, by exporting slaves to the vastly more advanced, technically and culturally sophisticated societies of North Africa and of Al-Andalus. So the slaves, the Slavs, are being led down through the Frankish lands. They come to Verdun, which is headquarters of Jewish doctors,
他们的顺从，他们被赋予了宽容。因为他们是《圣经》之民。这为我们可能称之为某种多元文化对话提供了空间。因此，穆斯林学者、基督教学者和犹太学者确实会面。我认为多元文化的角度可能被极大地夸大了。你可以理解为什么人们想要相信过去曾存在一个我们可以产生共鸣的多元文化天堂。老实说，在这一时期的欧洲背景下，最具多元文化的活动是奴隶贸易。因此，我们之所以把奴隶称为 slaves 而不是拉丁语 servi，是因为大批斯拉夫人被东部边境的萨克逊人和法兰克人绑架并奴役。这就是他们赚钱的方式，通过向北非和安达卢西亚那些在技术和文化上远为先进、精致的社会出口奴隶。因此，奴隶，即斯拉夫人，被经由法兰克人的领地带下去。他们来到凡尔登，那是犹太医生的总部，
who will there take the most beautiful slaves and castrate them, sometimes with a complete panoptomy. So everything gets removed. And these are massively, massively prized. And then they get taken to the courts of Al-Andalus and specifically to the court of the Caliph at Cordova. And it's not just eunuchs who are going, and it's not just female slaves to serve as concubines. It's also soldiers. Basically, by this point, the Muslims of Al-Andalus aren't really interested in going off and fighting
他们会在那里挑选最漂亮的奴隶并将他们阉割，有时甚至会进行完全切除。所以一切都被切除了。这些奴隶极受、极受青睐。然后他们被带到安达卢西亚的宫廷，特别是科尔多瓦的哈里发宫廷。不仅有被阉者被送去，不仅有充当妃嫔的女性奴隶，还有士兵。基本上，到这个时候，安达卢西亚的穆斯林已经对去远征、攻打
the barbarous Christians in the north. You know, they want to kind of hang around, enjoying the fruits of their incredible civilization. So the Caliph Abdul Rahman III is importing huge numbers of Slavic soldiers who are known as Saqaliba. And these are the soldiers that Abbot John, when he visits the Caliphate Palace, sees. And the reports get back to the Frankish lands and it's hailed by people there as this brilliant ornament. This is the most exquisite place in the world. It doesn't matter that it's a Muslim capital. It is seen as being the most wonderful place. And Abdulrahman presides over
北方的野蛮基督徒不怎么感兴趣了。你知道的，他们只想四处闲逛，享受他们不可思议的文明成果。因此，哈里发阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼三世（Abdul Rahman III）正大量进口被称为萨卡利巴（Saqaliba）的斯拉夫士兵。这些就是约翰阿伯特（Abjot John）访问哈里发宫殿时看到的士兵。这些消息传回了法兰克人的领地，并被那里的人们誉为绝妙的装饰。这是世界上最精致的地方。它是一个穆斯林首都这一点并不重要。它被视为最美妙的地方。阿卜杜勒拉赫曼主持着
this golden age. He rules for 49 years. But very sadly, he confides in his diary towards the end of his life that in all that time, he had only known 14 days of happiness. 14 days? 14 days. It's very exact. Yeah. Yeah. It's very sad. What happened on those 14 days? Many people have wondered.
这个黄金时代。他统治了49年。但非常遗憾的是，他在晚年的日记中吐露，在那段漫长的时间里，他只体验过14天的幸福。14天？14天。非常确切。是的。是的。这太令人悲伤了。那14天发生了什么？许多人一直在猜测。
So I've diligently numbered the days of pure and genuine happiness, which have fallen to my lot. They amount to 14. Yeah. I mean, he's very exact about it. Yeah, exactly. He's been counting them up. Yeah. But, you know, he's clearly a great ruler.
因此，我勤勉地记下了落在我头上的纯粹而真正的幸福日子。它们总共是14天。是的。我的意思是，他对此非常精确。是的，绝对精确。他一直在把它们加起来。是的。但是，你知道的，他显然是一位伟大的统治者。
Cordova reaches its kind of imperial apogee, but it's dependent on peace. Everything is very, very centralised. And the caliph himself, you know, out in his Versailles equivalent, is becoming increasingly isolated. So he spends an awful lot of time in his harem. Is that right, Tom? Well, this is the stereotype. We don't really know, but he definitely isolates himself
科尔多瓦达到了某种帝国鼎盛期，但它依赖于和平。一切都非常、非常集中。而哈里发本人，你知道的，在他那相当于凡尔赛宫的住所里，正变得越来越孤立。因此他在后宫里花了大量时间。是这样吗，汤姆？嗯，这是一种刻板印象。我们其实并不知道，但他确实将自己隔绝开来，
from the kind of the throng and the surge of Cordova itself. And a city like Cordova and an empire like that of the Umayyad Caliphate can only be maintained in conditions of peace. It's dependent on the existence of a bureaucracy. So when you have a virtuous circle, it upholds this kind of great imperial structure. But if the structure starts to fragment, if the conditions of peace that enable the economy to function and the bureaucracy to do what it has to do starts to go into decline, then you have a problem. It's not initially a problem after Abdul Rahman's death, because his son al-Hakam is a very effective caliph as well,
不再接触科尔多瓦本身的人潮与喧嚣。像科尔多瓦这样的城市以及乌玛亚哈里发国这样的帝国，只能在和平的条件下维持。它依赖于官僚机构的存在。所以，当你拥有一个良性循环时，它就能支撑这种伟大的帝国结构。但如果结构开始解体，如果使经济运转和官僚机构履行职责得以实现的和平条件开始走向衰落，那么你就会遇到麻烦。在阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼死后，这最初并不是一个问题，因为他的儿子阿尔-哈坎（al-Hakam）也是一位非常称职的哈里发，
very shrewd, very sophisticated. But then in 976 al-hakam is succeeded by his son who is 14 years old and this is a guy called hisham yeah and uh do you want to know what i took how a top historian has described the reign of hisham this is yourself tom he passed the entire span of his reign within the gilded cage of cordova citadel the anonymous and indolent victim of his own general uselessness oh golly i hope no one says that about you yeah it'd be very sad wouldn't it and this is also happening in in in baghdad as well there's a sense in which the caliph is is ceasing to be an actor and he's starting to become a cipher or a symbol or a phantom however you want to cast it in a way tom
非常精明，非常成熟老练。但随后在976年，阿尔-哈坎由他14岁的儿子继位，这家伙叫希沙姆（Hisham）。是的，呃，你想知道顶级历史学家是怎么形容希沙姆的统治的吗？这就是你说的，汤姆：他将自己统治的整个时期都度过了科尔多瓦城堡的镀金笼子里，成为自己毫无用处的匿名且懒散的受害者。噢天哪，我希望没人这样评价你。是的，那会很悲伤，不是吗？这也同样发生在巴格达，某种意义上，哈里发不再是一个行动者，而是开始变成一个密码、一个象征或者一个幻影，无论你想怎么去形容他。汤姆，
could you not argue that that is a tribute to the resilience, the sophistication of the bureaucracy? It doesn't need a single warlord to cow people, that actually the machine can run quite happily and he can mess around in his harem and drink his sherbet. Well, so what actually happens under the reign of Hisham II is that the effective master of the caliphate is seized by his vizier. So his prime minister, his main minister.
难道你不能认为这是对官僚机构的韧性和成熟度的赞颂吗？它不需要一个单一的军阀来恐吓人民，实际上机器可以非常愉快地运转，而他则可以在后宫里瞎胡闹、喝着他的果汁。好吧，那么在希沙姆二世统治期间实际发生的是，哈里发的实际统治权被他的维齐尔（vizier）夺去了。也就是他的首相，首席大臣。
And this is a guy who is called Ibn Amir. And he's a very celebrated warrior. He's a very distinguished religious scholar. He's very stern. He's very masterful. And in 981, he adopts the absolutely brilliant title of the victorious one, Al-Mansur. And basically, Al-Mansur, he despises the wealth and the sophistication and the glamour of Cordova. He sees it as decadent, as depraved, as dissipated. And he's desperate to see the Muslims of Cordova taken back to the good old days when they went off and fought with Christians and were austere and didn't just kind
这是一个名叫伊本·阿米尔（Ibn Amir）的家伙。他是一位著名的勇士。他是一位杰出的宗教学者。他非常严厉。他非常具有掌控力。在981年，他采用了绝对辉煌的称号“胜利者”——阿尔-曼苏尔（Al-Mansur）。基本上，阿尔-曼苏尔鄙视科尔多瓦的财富、成熟和魅力。他认为它是颓废的、堕落的、放荡的。他极度渴望看到科尔多瓦的穆斯林回到那些美好的旧时光，那时他们会去与基督徒作战，生活简朴，而不仅仅是
of sit around looking at giant pearls and stirring mercury pools and all that kind of stuff. And so he's resolved to correct it. And he does this in two ways. And the first is that he sets in train a very radical process of public reform. So scholars who are suspected of heresy are publicly crucified in Cordova. And he employs agents to go through the Caliphal Library and to winnow it of heretical texts. And these are then burnt in public bonfires. So the age of tolerance is definitively dead with this fellow. He's not in favor of tolerance at all. And the other measure of how he's not in favour of tolerance is that he is massively in favour of jihad. He is hugely in favour of that. So he goes
坐在那里看着巨大的珍珠、搅动水银池以及所有诸如此类的东西。因此，他决心纠正这一切。他通过两种方式做到这一点。首先，他开启了一个非常激进的公共改革进程。因此，被怀疑是异端的学者在科尔多瓦被公开钉死在十字架上。他雇佣特工搜查哈里发图书馆，剔除异端文本。这些文本随后在公共篝火中被焚烧。因此，宽容的时代对这个家伙来说绝对已经消亡了。他根本不支持宽容。他不支持宽容的另一个表现是，他极力支持圣战。他非常支持这一点。所以他
off, he burns Barcelona. He repeatedly invades the Kingdom of Leon, which is starting to emerge as one of the more powerful Christian kingdoms. And in 997, he attacks the holiest of all the Christian shrines in Northern Spain, which is Santiago de la Compostela, where supposedly St. James is buried. And there are various very improbable stories as to how St. James ends up buried in Santiago. And St. James, Santiago comes to be associated by the Christians with fighting the Moors. Obviously, this doesn't go down well with Almanzor. And so he launches this great attack on Santiago.
出发了，烧毁了巴塞罗那。他屡次入侵莱昂王国（Kingdom of Leon），该王国正开始崛起为更强大的基督教王国之一。公元997年，他袭击了西班牙北部所有基督教圣地中最神圣的地方，即圣地亚哥-德孔波斯特拉（Santiago de la Compostela），据说圣詹姆斯（St. James）就埋葬在那里。关于圣詹姆斯如何最终埋葬在圣地亚哥，有各种非常离奇的故事。圣詹姆斯，即圣地亚哥，逐渐被基督徒与抗击摩尔人联系在一起。显然，阿尔曼苏尔对这一点很不满。因此，他对圣地亚哥发动了这次大举进攻。
He occupies it for a week. He burns everything that he can. He destroys the cathedral. He plunders it. He takes large numbers of slaves. And when he marches back to Cordova, he makes Christian captives carry the bells from the cathedral all the way to Cordova, where they are hung up in the mosque and they are used as candle holders. And the Christian slaves he's brought are either set to work building
他占领了那里一个星期。他烧毁了所有他能烧的东西。他摧毁了座是大教堂。他对其进行了大肆劫掠。他掳走了大量的奴隶。当他撤军回科尔多瓦时，他让基督教俘虏把大教堂的钟一路抬到科尔多瓦，在那里它们被挂在清真寺里，用作烛台。他带来的基督教奴隶要么被派去修建
extension to the mosque, so make it even more domineering at the center in Cordova, or they're beheaded. And again, their heads are sent to the mosque. So again, this is very much a theme. You advertise your piety by beheading Christians and hanging them from the gates of the mosque. So all of this is about making, well, I suppose it's not about making the Caliphate of Cordova great again, because it's already great, but it's about making it holy again.
清真寺的扩建部分，使其在科尔多瓦的中心显得更加高耸威严，要么被斩首。同样，他们的头颅也被送到清真寺。所以这再次成为了一个非常鲜明的主题。你通过斩首基督徒并将他们挂在清真寺大门上来宣示你的虔诚。因此，这一切都是为了——好吧，我想这并不是为了让科尔多瓦哈里发国再次伟大，因为它已经很伟大了，而是为了让它再次圣洁。
Right, holy again. Properly Islamic again. But even though it looks as though it's the Christian kingdoms of the north that are being harrowed and gashed and wounded, the truth is that the whole time, even under Al-Mansur, this great conqueror, the seeds of the downfall of the Caliphate of Kordova itself are being sown because al-mansur when he goes on his wars he is more reluctant to rely on slavic slaves than his you know his caliphal predecessors had been and instead he recruits people from north africa so he recruits berbers yeah and they in the words of one muslim chronicler they are famed for their exploits their qualities and their valor in the face of the christians and these are the kind of guys that Al-Mansur wants.
没错，再次圣洁。重新变得彻底伊斯兰化。但尽管看起来似乎是北方的基督教王国遭受了蹂躏、割裂和重创，但事实是，整个过程，甚至在阿尔-曼苏尔这位伟大的征服者统治下，科尔多瓦哈里发国自身衰亡的种子就已经被种下了。因为阿尔-曼苏尔在进行战争时，比他的哈里发前任们更不愿意依赖斯拉夫奴隶。相反，他从北非招募人员——也就是招募柏柏尔人。是的，用一位穆斯林史家的话来说，他们“因在基督徒面前的战功、品质和勇猛而闻名”。这些正是阿尔-曼苏尔想要的人。
And so he recruits ever larger numbers of Berber war bands. He billets them across the caliphate. And the people in Cordova and beyond are not very keen on having a load of, as they see it, barbarian zealots kind of dumped on them, particularly since they're having to pay for them. So, you know, there aren't enough Christians to fund them now. So Muslims are having to be taxed and they don't like this. They don't like having to pay for these guys. And so as the tax rate spirals upwards, the resentment of people in Al-Andalus towards the Berbers escalates, particularly in Cordova, but also beyond it, you start to get this great swirl of ethnic hatreds, incredible hostility on the part of
因此，他招募了越来越多的柏柏尔雇佣军团。他将他们分驻在哈里发国的各处。科尔多瓦及其他地方的人民并不太乐意看到一堆在他们看来是野蛮的狂热分子被倾倒在他们头上，尤其是因为他们还得为这些人付钱。所以，你知道的，现在已经没有足够的基督徒来资助他们了。因此，穆斯林不得不纳税，他们不喜欢这样。他们不喜欢为这些家伙买单。因此，随着税率螺旋式上升，安达卢西亚人民对柏柏尔人的怨恨情绪不断升级，尤其是在科尔多瓦，而且在其他地方也是如此，你开始感受到一股强烈的民族仇恨漩涡，
the inhabitants of al-Andalus towards these, as they see it, barbarian immigrants. And so this is not religious. This is purely ethnic, basically. It's basically, yeah, it's basically ethnic. They don't like them. They don't like them. 1002, Al-Mansur dies, and he's succeeded as vizier by his son, Abdul Malik, very popular name in this period. Abdul Malik, unlike his dad, is an alcoholic, but he's also very keen on jihad. So he's very expert. So it seems to kind of tick along. He goes off and, you know, does his stuff on the northern frontier. But then in 1008, he dies and is succeeded by his brother, who is the son of a Christian concubine and is disdainfully known by everyone in Cordova as Sanchuelo. He's a very devout Muslim, but he has this kind of mocking name. And Sanchuelo forces poor old Hisham II, who's still very much around in his gilded cage being useless.
安达卢西亚居民对这些他们眼中的野蛮移民抱有难以置信的敌意。所以这不是宗教问题。这基本上纯粹是民族问题。基本上是，是的，基本上是民族问题。他们不喜欢他们。他们不喜欢他们。1002年，阿尔-曼苏尔去世，他的儿子阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik）接替他担任维齐尔，这个名字在这一时期非常受欢迎。与他的父亲不同，阿卜杜勒·马利克是个酒鬼，但他也非常热衷于圣战。所以他非常熟练。所以一切似乎都在顺利进行。他出发了，你知道的，在北部边境做他该做的事。但在1008年，他去世了，由他的弟弟继位，他是基督教妃嫔的儿子，在科尔多瓦被所有人轻蔑地称为桑丘埃洛（Sanchuelo）。他是一个非常虔诚的穆斯林，但有着这样一个嘲讽的外号。桑丘埃洛迫使可怜的希沙姆二世——他仍然在镀金的笼子里无所事事地存在着——
He forces Hisham to name Sanctuelo as heir. Sanctuelo is absolutely not a diplomat. So he forces everyone at court to start wearing Berber fashions and Berber style of turban. So this goes down like a cup of cold sick. He gallops off on Jihad to the north. And while he's away, an Umayyad fugitive sneaks into Cordova, rallies all the other Umayyads who've basically been dispossessed by this new family of viziers, deposes Hisham II and lays claim to be caliph. And basically, he says to the Cordovans, the Umayyads are back. Everything's back to normal. Let's pile in.
他迫使希沙姆将桑丘埃洛指定为继承人。桑丘埃洛绝对不是个外交家。因此，他强迫宫廷里的所有人都开始穿柏柏尔人的时装，戴柏柏尔风格的头巾。所以这就像喝了一杯冷倒胃口的药水一样不受欢迎。他骑马飞奔到北方去参加圣战。当他不在的时候，一个乌玛亚王朝的逃犯潜入科尔多瓦，召集了其他所有基本上被这个新维齐尔家族剥夺了财产的乌玛亚人，废黜了希沙姆二世，并宣称自己是哈里发。基本上，他对科尔多瓦人说，乌玛亚家族回来了。一切都恢复正常了。让我们一起上吧。
And so lots of Cordovans rally to his cause. They burst into the palace. They invade the harem. They grab all the most beautiful women, kind of parcel them out among themselves. And then when they learn that Sanctuelo, who's up in the north fighting the Christians, has been assassinated, his corpse is brought back. It's stuck up on a gibbet. And this new caliph goes so far that he puts a bounty on the head of every Berber in Cordova and beyond. And so this unleashes an absolute orgy of carnage and bloodshed. You get huge mobs spilling out. They're being given money for every Berber head that they can find.
于是，许多科尔多瓦人团结在他的旗帜下。他们冲进皇宫。他们闯入后宫。他们抢走了所有最漂亮的女人，把她们在自己人中间瓜分。然后，当他们得知在北方与基督徒作战的桑丘埃洛被暗杀时，他的尸体被运了回来。它被挂在绞刑架上。这位新哈里发甚至悬赏科尔多瓦及其他地方的每一个柏柏尔人的头颅。于是这引发了一场绝对的大屠杀和流血狂欢。大批暴徒涌上街头。他们每找到一颗柏柏尔人的头颅就会得到一笔钱。
And so there's huge mass slaughter. Their women are raped, tethered together to be sold as slaves. Pregnant women have their babies cut out of their wombs. It's a monstrous scene. And of course, it's a terrible, terrible mistake. Because even though they've wiped out all the Berbers in Cordifer, they have not wiped out all the Berbers in Al-Andalus. And these are guys who are very, very proficient at warfare. They're not going to take this kind of treatment lightly. And so they form a great army and they lay Cordova under siege in 1010. The Caliph, the Umayyad Caliph who has set all this in motion,
因此发生了大规模屠杀。他们的女性被强奸，被拴在一起当作奴隶出售。怀孕妇女的胎儿被从子宫里剖出。这是一个骇人听闻的景象。当然，这是一个极其严重的错误。因为尽管他们消灭了科尔多瓦的所有柏柏尔人，但他们并没有消灭安达卢西亚的所有柏柏尔人。这些人是非常、非常精通战争的。他们不会轻易对待这种待遇。因此，他们在1010年组建了一支庞大的军队，将科尔多瓦包围。哈里发，即引发这一切的乌玛亚哈里发，
the Cordovans realize this has been a terrible mistake. So they depose him and restore Hisham II, who's still kind of on the on the scene he's very much the henry the sixth of right yeah the the emmaid caliphate and they endure a three-year siege and desperate scenes cannibalism eating leather eating rats all that kind of stuff and after three years each the burbers break in complete slaughter put it absolutely to the torch. Hisham II, at last, it's presumed is killed. So he's finally gone. And this great, golden, wealthy city, a city that can compare with Constantinople or Baghdad, is put to the torch, and it will never again reclaim that golden primacy, nor ever again will there be a ruler who can lay claim to a kind of caliphal status. You do get spectral caliphs, but they're rulers of nothing. And you start to get
科尔多瓦人意识到这是一个巨大的错误。于是他们废黜了他，并恢复了希沙姆二世的职位，他仍然留在局中，简直就像是乌玛亚哈里发国里的亨利六世，对，没错。他们经受了长达三年的围城和绝望的景象：人吃人、吃皮革、吃老鼠以及所有诸如此类的东西。三年围城后，柏柏尔人攻破了城池，进行了彻底的大屠杀，把它付之一炬。人们推测希沙姆二世终于被杀了。所以他最终还是走了。这座伟大、黄金般富饶的城市——一座可以与君士坦丁堡或巴格达相媲美的城市——被付之一炬，它将再也无法恢复那种黄金时代的至高地位，也再不会出现一个能够宣称拥有某种哈里发地位的统治者。你确实会看到幽灵般的哈里发，但他们是空头统治者。你开始看到
increasing numbers of Muslim rulers who don't even tend to be caliphs, so local warlords. And this is a process of fragmentation that leaves al-andalus kind of shattered now this is what they call the fitna isn't it the fitna yes sort of anarchy or civil war or whatever that lasts for what 20 years well it lasts yeah i mean it actually lasts for you know it it's never reunited it fragments into different kingdoms and it's this of course that enables the predatory christian kingdoms of the north to start really really reclaiming the Visigothic lands that have been lost. And, you know, within a century of the sack of Cordova, Toledo has been retaken and the kings of Castile and Leon are really starting to press southwards. So the thing that's amazing about the Caliphate of Cordova is the incredible pinnacle of sophistication and wealth and glamour that it attains.
越来越多的穆斯林统治者甚至不再充当哈里发，而是变成了地方军阀。这是一个解体的过程，让安达卢西亚如今变得四分五裂。现在，这就是他们所说的“菲特纳”（fitna），不是吗？菲特纳，是的，某种无政府状态或内战之类的，持续了多少年？20年？嗯，它持续了——是的，我的意思是它实际上持续了——它再也没有重新统一，而是分裂成了不同的王国。当然，正是这一点使得北方虎视眈眈的基督教王国能够真正开始收复那些失落的西哥特领土。而且，在科尔多瓦洗劫后的一個世纪内，托莱多已经被收复，卡斯蒂利亚和莱昂的国王们正真正开始向南推进。因此，科尔多瓦哈里发国最令人惊叹的是它所达到的那种令人难以置信的精致、财富和魅力的巅峰。
And then the utter implosion. Yeah. And it's an extraordinary story. Of course, Muslim Spain endures for a very, very long time after this, you know, right the way up to the age of Ferdinand and Isabella. Granada doesn't fall to 1492, but it's, you know, the balance of power with the sack of cordova shifts from from muslim spain to christian spain yeah so the granada stuff because people often think of granada and the alhambra when they think of islamic spain but that's really just an epilogue isn't it it's kind of afterthought the high point is cordova in what the 10th century yeah yeah it's the 10th
然后是彻底的内爆。是的。这是一个非凡的故事。当然，在此之后，穆斯林西班牙存续了非常、非常长的时间，你知道的，一直延续到费尔南德斯和伊abella的时代。格拉纳达直到1492年才陷落，但你知道，随着科尔多瓦的洗劫，权力平衡从穆斯林西班牙转移到了基督教西班牙。是的，所以关于格拉纳达的事——因为人们在想到伊斯兰西班牙时，往往会想到格拉纳达和阿尔罕布拉宫，但那其实只是一段尾声，不是吗？它有点像个事后的想法。最高峰是10世纪的科尔多瓦，对吧？是的，那是10
century and in terms of the sort of the culture, Tom, the philosophy, literature, science, am I right in thinking that Cordoba is a kind of oasis of all this? Okay. So our view of the early medieval period, and maybe you will say this is now, this is a very late 20th, early 21st century, sort of, as it were, a liberal projection. The common view is, you know, that Islamic Spain, the Caliphate of Cordoba, is an oasis of intellectualism and thought and people engaging with the classical legacy, while out in the sticks, the Christians are living in mud. It is, it is. So the Caliph of Cordobava sees himself as, say, an equal of the Emperor in Constantinople and has good relations with him. So the Emirates had always been accused by the Arabs of a habit called a Qasariya, so behaving like a Caesar. And so the Emperor in Constantinople and the Caliph in Cordova, they kind of swap books. They send messengers, they view each other as being kind of
世纪。就某种文化而言，汤姆，哲学、文学、科学，我没记错的话，科尔多瓦是这一切的绿洲，对吗？好的。所以我们对中世纪早期的看法——也许你会说这现在是，这是一种非常20世纪末、21世纪初的、某种意义上的自由派投射。普遍的观点是，你知道的，伊斯兰西班牙，科尔多瓦哈里发国，是知识分子和思想以及人们接触古典遗产的绿洲，而住在偏远地区的基督徒则生活在泥潭里。确实，确实如此。因此，科尔多瓦的哈里发把自己看作是，比如说，君士坦丁堡皇帝的平等对等者，并与他保持着良好的关系。因此，埃米尔们一直被阿拉伯人指责有一种叫做“阿萨里亚”（Qasariya）的习惯，即表现得像个凯撒。因此，君士坦丁堡的皇帝和科尔多瓦的哈里发，他们会交换书籍。他们派遣信使，他们将彼此视为某种
equals. The Caliph views, say, the kings of Germany, Otto the Great and his heirs, with a kind of mild contempt. I mean, he sends books to the emperor in Constantinople, he sends wild animals to Otto, because these are the kind of things that will impress a barbarian. And the kind of community of scholarship that the Caliphate presides over means that all kinds of texts can be imported into Cordova. So Aristotle famously, and in due course, when Toledo is captured, Toledo becomes a great center of translation, presided over by Christian kings, but with Muslim scholars and Christian scholars and Jewish scholars all working together. And that really is, you know, this idea of the tolerance and the dialogue. And absolutely, that's a part of it. The idea that there is a kind of community of scholars that perhaps transcends the sectarianism that also very powerfully exists because it has to, you know, it has to be said that there is a lot of beheading of Christians going on. This is happening.
平等的人。哈里发对待德国国王，比如大奥托（Otto the Great）及其继承人时，带有一种轻微的蔑视。我的意思是，他向君士坦丁堡的皇帝赠送书籍，向奥托赠送野生动物，因为这些是能打动野蛮人的东西。哈里发所主持的这种学术共同体意味着各种文本都可以被输入到科尔多瓦。因此，正如人们所熟知的亚里士多德，以及适时地，当托莱多被攻占时，托莱多成了一个伟大的翻译中心，由基督教国王主持，但有穆斯林学者、基督教学者和犹太学者共同工作。这确实是——你知道的，这种宽容和对话的理念。绝对的，这是其中的一部分。这种学者的共同体理念，也许超越了宗派主义，尽管宗派主义也极其强烈地存在着，因为必须指出的是，当时有很多基督徒被斩首。这确实正在发生。
And 1066, a date famous in England, there is a pogrom of Jews in Granada. So it's not like Christians and Jews are treated as equals. They're not. They're institutionally inferior. But that institutional inferiority means that there is a place for them. The difference between say that the role that say that jews have in christian europe is that there isn't a religiously prescribed role for the jews because in the new testament it makes no sense to think of it in those terms
而在英国历史上著名的1066年，格拉纳达发生了一场针对犹太人的大屠杀。所以这并不像是基督徒和犹太人被同等对待。他们不是。他们在制度上处于劣势。但这种制度上的劣势意味着他们有一席之地。与犹太人在基督教欧洲所扮演的角色相比，区别在于，犹太人在那里并没有一种宗教上规定的角色，因为在新约中，从这些词汇来思考是没有意义的
whereas in the quran there is a sense of jews and christians existing and so their treatment can be prescribed by by the quran but every multicultural, there has to be a dominant society. Our dominant framework is a secular one. You know, we prescribe freedom of religion, but we don't prescribe freedom of religion to the degree that to do what they want to do, to practice their faith, to study one another, whatever. But the framework is absolutely a Muslim one. And people who offend against that, you know, will be dealt with. So two questions before we wrap up. Question number one, if you have to live anywhere in 10th century Europe, you know, the time machine condemns you to life in Western Europe.
而在《古兰经》中，确实存在犹太人和基督徒存在的观念，因此对他们的待遇可以通过《古兰经》来规定。但是，每一个多元文化社会，都必须有一个主导社会。我们的主导框架是世俗的。你知道的，我们规定了宗教信仰自由，但我们并没有将宗教信仰自由规定到允许人们随心所欲、践行信仰、互相研究等等的地步。然而，这里的框架绝对是穆斯林框架。而违背这一框架的人，你知道的，将会受到处理。所以在我们结束之前有两个问题。第一个问题，如果你必须生活在10世纪欧洲的某个地方，时间机器注定你在西欧度过一生，
Is Cordoba the obvious place to choose? Oh, I think Malmesbury. Malmesbury. The court of Athelstan. Right. There's no sherbets and fountains there, right? I think if you want running water and baths and libraries and all that kind of stuff and imports from China and the Indian Ocean. Frankly, those sound very good to me. Cordoba is the only place to be.
科尔多瓦是显而易见的选择吗p？哦，我认为是马姆斯伯里（Malmesbury）。马姆斯伯里。阿塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）的宫廷。对。那里没有果汁和喷泉，对吧？我想如果你想要自来水、浴室、图书馆以及所有诸如此类的东西，还有来自中国和印度洋的进口货。坦白说，这些听起来对我都很好。科尔多瓦是唯一的好去处。
Okay. And so the second question, is there, I mean, I know we have many times had great fun pouring scorn on what ifs, but is there an alternative history in which the Caliphate of Cordoba survives or evolves in some way so that there is there an alternative history in which the Caliphate of Cordoba survives or evolves in some way so that there is still an Islamic Spain today? I think so. Yeah, I think so. I don't think there's anything inevitable about it. I mean, it's not just about the weakness of the state structures in Cordoba. It's also about the growing strength of the Christian kings. And that reflects a kind of a growing self-confidence that's economic, that's religious, that's cultural on the part of the Christians of Northern Europe. So who knows?
好的。那么第二个问题，是否有——我知道我们曾多次对“如果”这种假设进行嘲弄，但是否存在一种替代历史，即科尔多瓦哈里发国以某种方式存续或演变，从而在今天的西班牙仍然存在一个伊斯兰政权？我想是的。是的，我想是的。我不认为有什么是不可避免的。我的意思是，这不仅仅关乎科尔多瓦国家结构的脆弱性。这也关乎基督教王国日益增长的力量。这反映了一种经济、宗教和文化上日益增长的自信，这种自信来自北欧的基督徒。所以谁知道呢？
I think it would be, you could imagine an alternative timeline where there is still an Islamic presence in Southern Spain. It's fascinating. I think we'll have to come back to the Reconquista. Well, if you think about it, I mean, we talked about in our history of Portugal about the attempt by the Portuguese to conquer North Africa. Yeah. If they'd done that, perhaps we'd be saying, well, can you imagine a counterfactual in which Morocco is still Muslim? Of course.
我想这会是——你可以想象一个替代的时间线，在那个时间线里，西班牙南部仍然存在伊斯兰教的存在。这太迷人了。我想我们还得回过头来谈谈收复失地运动。好吧，如果你仔细想想，我的意思是，我们在关于葡萄牙历史的节目中谈到过葡萄牙人征服北非的企图。是的。如果他们做到了这一点，也许我们就会说，“嗯，你能想象一个反事实的历史，即摩洛哥仍然是穆斯林的吗？”当然。
So who knows? Interesting questions. Tom, that was absolutely fascinating. The best thing about it, as with quite a lot of these World Cup-themed podcasts, is that it really made me, while I was listening to you, want to go back to Cordoba and go and see the Mezquita and all that sort of stuff. So the Spanish Tourist Board should be very grateful to you.
所以谁知道呢？有趣的问题。汤姆，这绝对太迷人了。最棒的部分是，正如许多以世界杯为主题的播客一样，它真的让我——当我在听你讲的时候——想回到科尔多瓦去看看清真寺大教堂和所有诸如此类的东西。所以西班牙旅游局应该非常感谢你。
I hope so. Thank you so much to all of you for listening. And we will see you next time. So thank you, Tom, and goodbye. Hasta luego. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
希望如此。非常感谢所有收听节目的听众。我们下期再见。谢谢你，汤姆，再见。下次见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，以及在我们问答环节中为你揭开
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。